i will test it on here i believe we are
going
live now on the interwebs
if you can see us give us a thumbs up
let's see
give us a a comment we are blind we are
flying blind
even worse than normal we are flying
blind
he's here he's here indeed he's in
person
he's covered free and he's loving it i
am loving it too
talking about none other than
dr eric weinstein how are you sir you're
behind me dr
professor brian keating this is an
experiment can you guys hear me out
there
say yes or no alex bilzerian how are you
thumbs up
hello everybody welcome to this fourth
edition of the week
of the into the impossible podcast join
live and in person and direct
with your friend and mine dr eric
weinstein hello eric how are you sir
all the way back down here at the
university of california at san diego
we've been working all day on new
theories and new experimental techniques
and i thought it only fair to let in
some of my audience to get to know you
better
in the world of physics and math that
makes you tick um now i'm going to see
if people can hear eric so
eric they're saying they can't hear you
so well can you can you scooch on over
scotch and over still in the frame
is that better let's see give us a
thumbs up if you can hear eric is that
better
all right this is great all right that's
it uh that was all we wanted to do
good night shabbat shalom no we are
going to go
and have a wide-ranging conversation
with the
one and only the effervescent eric
weinstein
so we've been talking a lot about
theories of everything today and that's
been a lot of fun for me
let me just see the chat in the chat
room i want to make sure we get
questions answered we decided to do and
ask me anything
really about uh eric asking eric
anything and i'll tag along for the ride
i did get one comment that i want to
start off with
and then i'm going to exalt my uh host
prerogative
different points during the conversation
but the first question is
you pitch yourself as an outsider in
physics and yet
you've had opportunities that many
people would die for being a postdoc
at prestigious institutions around the
world
why do you consider yourself an outsider
in physics why don't you
consider yourself more closer to an
insider in that you've done these things
on the inner level at the highest levels
of theoretical physics
what's an interesting question i would
say that first of all there's an issue
of respect
whatever my issues are with the
theoretical physics community i view it
as being
probably the most important intellectual
community that we have
and i don't think that an outsider says
i'm a physicist
i think that that's an occasional
privilege that
physicists dole out and i'm not so
presumptuous to think
that i am one i mean there's a there's a
there's a physics sequence right and it
has to do with
a couple of semesters of mechanics of
electromagnetism of quantum theory
of thermodynamics of this i've had only
one of the regular courses
which is the mechanics the first
semester of mechanics
so whatever it is it's not the standard
sequence
so i guess in part it's the same it's
the same thing as in economics
if you haven't taken the classes if you
haven't come up the standard sequence
you
you owe it to people to let them know
that you are not coming at this
from the expected perspective
so it's more of a kind of uh human out
of humility out of respect deference for
the true physicists that are working
cradle to grave in physics you know when
you
when you're the sort of a person who's
giving your all to compute
perturbation series and to make sure
that you don't drop a minus sign over
seven pages of calculations
i got all the respect in the world for
people
who do theoretical physics
professionally for a living and take it
seriously
and yeah i mean i think that there's
also just
it's just professional respect i'm not a
physicist by my own
understanding of what it is a physical i
mean i play the guitar but i'm not a
guitarist
so it's the same sort of a thing i
recognize what it takes to be those
things do you feel like an outsider
under those definitions can actually be
accepted by the
orthodoxy of physics leaving aside the
point of whether or not
you can actually contribute something as
a non-physicist
on my worst day with respect to my
feelings about the theoretical physics
community i don't think it's ever been
so corrupt
that it would turn down a right answer
if somebody from outside the community
could come up with it no matter how
horrible that person is now whether
the community was gracious about it
whether they put somebody else's name on
it whether they did
there are all sorts of things you can
fault physicists for doing but
i've never known them to turn down the
right answer
in service of doing something stupid
when they've understood that both are
options
okay we have our first question coming
in from the audience here
this is from youth and this is a
paradigmatic
question i get asked a lot i've got he
has a or she has a theory two new fields
of math that deal in analog quantities
they allow for hyper computation and
pianos axioms
analog matrices and point wave geometry
how should i gift them
to the world what would you say to such
a person realizing that sometimes people
might think what you talk about in
geometric unity
is analogous but let's say let's put it
in the same terms then yeah okay let's
do it
um the key issue is the following
when you ask people to evaluate your
work
and brian we have to come up with some
way that people aren't looking quite so
directly into your scout yes i know my
bald spot is going to be revealed
okay there we go how about this
all right i think it goes like this
people don't understand that the major
cost in evaluating a theory is time
and so if you if you have the most
brilliant thing in the world first of
all recognize that you're almost
certainly lying to yourself
and this is this is the painful thing
that people will not
tell aspiring outsiders
in general almost everything that comes
in from outside is
is wrong and so the quick cut
is if somebody isn't playing by the
rules the reason there's only one reason
not to play by the rules and that's that
you don't have anything and you want to
believe that you have something
so whether you're trying to fool us
directly or trying to fool yourself
first and us secondarily
the suspicion is that if you don't do
things the usual way
there's only one reason it's because you
don't really have anything
and that's the biggest thing that you're
up against what you're up against is
people will feel that you're wasting
their time and that you're threatening
their credibility
and they won't tell you those things
they'll say things like well just write
it up put it on the archive
break off an experiment show show what
your theory does that no other theory
does
and i don't think any of those things
are likely to work for a long time
because
honestly your theory is not going to get
read and
your the major fear people will have
that they won't tell you is that
maybe they'll think your theory is right
and they won't catch how wrong it is
and then they're going to look like an
ass in front of their colleagues and
that's why nobody wants to do this stuff
yeah we were talking earlier today about
the tortured path that einstein took
to get to the general theory of
relativity
starting in i believe 1913 he came up
with a very crude
estimation marcel grossman grossman yeah
and and grossman was of course
instrumental into the
eventual you know wide acceptance of the
theory of relativity
they were competing but they were also
called deeply collaborative i think they
were really much more collaborative than
they were competing
um but everything that uh succeeds needs
a story and sometimes a story of
competition is the one that sells
uh and but anyway the 1913 1914 1950
1916 until 1917
when the final version of gr comes out
and it includes something that later
would be
apocryphally called his greatest blunder
einstein's great that's hearsay but yes
yes exactly mario olivia who's been on
my podcast the into the impossible
podcast oh and i want to remind people
out there
i've done you know what 17 interviews
just this month alone with nobel prize
winners
friends like my friend eric weinstein
and others scientists and not
and so please do me the favor of
subscribing liking thumbs-upping or
whatever is that even a verb
but i know that you need exercise every
doctors tell you to exercise your
fingers so push the subscribe button
while we're talking um so this tortured
path that i'm saying not to mention for
eric weinstein's channel yes eric
weinstein you have a small channel of
but come on uh uh the question is
uh you know the provisional nature can
you imagine
gr being accepted in the age of twitter
and i don't mean like oh it's just
stupid
but like actually legitimate questions
about the inadequacies of the theory in
1913 as compared to the final version
and then the final version has this big
bang you know laying within it
so to speak yeah yeah the um
i think that in large measure we know
that the twitter sphere would crap all
over general relativity as the world
sort of crapped on it until it realized
through eddington's work that this had
powerful predictive
power and even then there was stinginess
about it so i think
the answer tends to be that when
something really big happens
we're very frightened to imagine that
things could really change because
nobody wants egg on their face and in
general that's what happens when new
things
are proposed as we find out they're not
nearly as cool or correct
and and and and you know i know that
that's by the way what i'm up against
um people imagine that you don't
understand
what it sounds like to be thinking about
these things and you don't understand
what the issues are but you know
definitely
these are the issues all right we have a
question from good mother
a super chat which pays my college kids
uh kids college tuition
and i give a portion to eric no no he
doesn't
um super chat asking our good mother
asking is freedom of speech the answer
to geometric unity
i don't know i don't know what that
means okay i don't think so yes or no
we had another super chat and that is
from
pie to nine decimal places super chat
pie i'll donate every hour pour a drink
take your time keep it going
that's not a question but i'll allow it
for 10 bucks
we go back to this uh to the uh a
preceding question here
i had a question about uh
let's see someone about oh yes this is
from reza
habib reza says i'm currently a third
year mathematics student with an
interest in mathematical physics
further uh what specific areas of math
would you advise me to explore further
topics within differential geometry um
boy i would recommend
look some of the let me give you a few
books that i think
changed my life uh completely one is
would be einstein manifolds by bess
which is actually a fictitious
collective like bourbon key that
happened to write
a book that's not really about einstein
manifold's best book on differential
geometry i've ever seen
i think it went out of print there's
another book called spin geometry by
michelson
uh which i would highly recommend
there's an old paper by iguchi gilkey
and hanson
which was how geometric methods were
sold to physicists to begin with
it was really a book but it came out as
if it were an article
to make it timely that i think is worth
going back to
um and i would say that
um those are oh the book
called geometric quantization by
woodhouse i would highly recommend
in and that gets you all the way up to
the idea that quantum field theory is
now best understood
as an enhanced form of borderism from
differential topology in many cases
and i would look up modern treatments of
quantum field theory topological field
theory conformal theory
field theory is enhanced borderism and
go from there but those books
are terrific including i guess there's
also a book by
getzler berlin and veron
on heat op heat heat equation methods
in tia singer index theory which i would
highly recommend there's a book called
um differential geometry
quantization and physics something like
that one of these green and white books
by was that the one by cecile moret do
we
the the three women yes i think that's
it and they have two volumes and those
those books were great when they were
written i don't know if they're really
up to date
mama iraqi is asking uh how would alpha
fold revolutionize the natural wine
industry
specifically with regards to varietals
and terroir oh this is uh
let me get my bottle of simon's
observatory select while eric
contemplates this question
well i guess what the question is is if
we can understand the three-dimensional
conformal properties of various proteins
using alpha
fold can we effectively figure out
through gas chromatography and
experiment and design
how to come up with wines that are ever
more
uh interesting in terms of uh enhancing
old world grapes i don't know this is
like really
this is a terroir has some to some
extent been discredited
tara was sort of the theory that the
french tell us that it's
something about the piece of land the
way that the wind hits it
and the way the sun shines on the vines
that is
indescribable and therefore can only be
done in france but of course
the university of california davis they
focused us much more on varietals
in the idea that terroir was to some
extent marketing [ __ ]
um although there's still a component of
it and so
i would say that's sort of how i read it
if i even understand your
crazy but wonderful question speaking of
beverages so this is simon's observatory
select so this is a friend of mine
a friend of yours maybe too michael
shermer has a buddy here in san diego i
forget his name
but he makes fine engraved glass bottles
and we had one made with a glenn livet
which we're not going to partake in
again because it's so it's it's
it's bad to drink two nights in a row
and we we had some fine is the first i
hear of this clearly not a russian but
we are going to have
some jocko go right now this is for we
don't get any pennies on this in fact
jocko will not come on my show he will
not answer my emails
as much as i'd love to have him on the
show but we'll do a free plug to jocko
uh go and what is this what am i putting
in my business is an energy drink that
oh enhances
and force multiplies your cognitive
abilities has anyone tried this out
there i'm a little bit worried
you don't want to try it well my friend
melissa chen tried an energy drink on
the joe rogan program and i think
went into the beginning of cardiac
arrest so i think
i think i'm going to hold up we've got a
good medical center just one across the
street over there
okay i'll tell you what i think of the
terroir of the jocko okay very good
which i think comes from maine has
anyone tried this uh
it's interesting it's it's kind of like
coconut
uh pina colada mixed with a red bull
okay phillip i can't pronounce your last
name i'm so sorry
cevednik uh what stop moving
okay what do you think hi eric just
wondering if you had any thoughts on the
p versus np problem wow
talk about a simple question what is p
versus np
really quickly and then do you have any
thoughts on it i i really don't it's one
of the hilbert problems having to do
with computational complexity
uh other problems
that can be described in one way are
guaranteed
sort of solvable within certain limits
um
i don't really think that i i think i'm
overextended enough without wanting to
get into the riemann hypothesis or p
equals np two of the most famous
unsolved problems
uh that come out of mathematics and
computers we're getting a question
or comment about the discord server
i don't think we'll take that i don't
understand it i've tried to log on to
this cord server i'm having a lot of
trouble
with it there's been some issues with
the community bifurcating one of the
things that i found out is that
academics and trolls have a lot in
common
and if you give academics the ability to
become trolls then you've got a problem
with academic trolling which i didn't
know was a thing but
is very much oh i love this in the eigen
bros i follow the eigen bros the
feeling is not mutual but eigen
burroughs asking about two brothers
eric and brett who would win in a fight
two men enter who leaves first of all if
you listen to my third essay on my most
recent release we don't
throw other people under buses nor do we
sell ourselves short
and we don't say we got your back no we
do if you have someone's back we don't
if you just
think it sounds cool okay this is an
interesting question from luke gamble
eric you have a personal kind of life
association with moses
uh would you talk to us about that less
interested in just time to get off the
planet
more and whether you choose such a myth
or if it chose you
that's deep well i do feel like we have
to get off the planet and i do
feel that um only physics can get us
off the planet and i do think that the
reason that we have to get off the
planet has not been
it's been very recent it's only since
1952 through 54 that we have to get off
the planet and it has to do with the
power that we were able to unlock
in physics and biology and so would you
have unleashed it if you could go back
to the 50s
you know some say apocryphally or not
einstein's letter to roosevelt etc
he understood the implications that was
lurking within the
within the theory um would you you know
kill einstein's grandfather
would you have prevented this from
happening if i was a better person i'd
contemplate that
i can't even contemplate that and
actually the completeness question oh
sorry go ahead
but the other thing is there was no way
out we were always destined
if you let cephalopods if you let
cuttlefish develop long enough
eventually cuttlefish would have fused
the atomic nuclei
right so the problem is with the problem
is with hydrogen
right the fact that you confuse hydrogen
while on earth
with a little bit of mathematics uh
it was always there and it's always been
like that and there's no way out
and so i really i think that in some
sense we we can blame zillard we can
blame teller we can blame einstein
but that's not the culprit the culprit
is human ingenuity
and the fact that we are smarter than we
are wise
i think the real uh the real
analogy would be the promised land is on
earth i mean you have no interest in
space right and it's not like you want
to go to mars
i don't want to leave the earth the
promised land is staying on earth not
like moses didn't right no i don't agree
with that you want to get off the earth
it's not question if i want to i think
that the promised land
wasn't much egypt was a nicer place it
had indoor plumbing
maybe it had streets who knows what it
had it had something
but you have to know when it's time to
leave and that's the point is is that we
can't stay here unless we're going to
get a lot smarter so some people are
gambling that we can get smarter and i'm
gambling that we actually
have worn out our welcome here and that
we better spread out so that some of us
don't blow up every
everything yeah question from succulent
succulents hello eric have you had a
serious look at stephen wolfram's
and teams physics projects well you may
not remember
mr mrs succulents that we did a podcast
together in fact it's coming up on 100
000 download views at least on youtube
my most popular episode featuring my
handsome friend here
and uh that did involve one of these
books that i have over here yeah a
project and steven is a friend of ours
on the show and he is gracious with his
time as well
quick thoughts since that podcast any
new developments have you looked into it
anymore
yeah i mean i think you roughly speaking
stephen is very interested in certain
roles that he thinks can generate
geometry
and that through geometry he will
generate physics and
he believes that these simple rules
are on the verge of doing it and i wish
him the best of luck
okay so let's see oh kevin flowers with
a big ticket item i'll pay for
one tenth of one of my kids uh college
textbooks
kevin which books would you recommend
applying gage theory so you gave your
general overview of books
both in the realm of economics like with
your work with the lovely and talented
pia milani
and or other fields more broadly very
good question kevin
so i would say that first of all the
first
chapter of pia milani's dissertation
so we did this joint work engaged theory
in economics but she wrote up the first
chapter of pedagogically aware
that economists didn't know anything
about the fiber bundles and connections
in parallel transport
so i would say that that happens to be
probably the finest
general introduction to this stuff even
though it happens to be in the service
of economics but that makes it quite
concrete
so i would say that really gage theory
hasn't been successfully applied
outside of differential topology
geometry and the math side
and fundamental physics on the physics
side
and this will be applied everywhere that
differential
calculus is applied once people figure
out that gage theory isn't some remote
thing it's just a version of the
differential calculus
oh sorry yeah so i had a thought that
just as gage theory
you know kind of applies economically as
you as pia
and you discussed which i should point
out was uh was popularized by juan mal
the cena who's been on
well juan mata used it he used pia's
thesis in particular
um originally not citing it but when he
but he
he he did use it and we i spoke to him
about it
as the basis for how to explain his
receipt of the
what is it the millennial pro the
breakthrough prize
uh of yuri milner and mark zuckerberg
so he had to explain how he was linking
string theory engaged theory to explain
gage theory he used foreign exchange
mechanisms
building on the work that pni did that
appears in her thesis so it
you can also take a look at his uh his
lecture explaining that at the institute
for advanced yeah i have uh i did an
interview with him about two months ago
on this podcast i did a live chat with
him
and i brought that up and he did
acknowledge that you guys were the
source of it but you're right and i can
say this eric can't
but this does appear very often so what
happens i did an interview with kamran
vapha which will be appearing hopefully
on tuesday
and in cameron's new wonderful book a
problem or puzzles to unlock the
universe i have it somewhere around here
at the end of the book he describes gage
theory and he doesn't cite he cites juan
maldasena's paper on uh
yeah on this so so you have to be
careful and you have to do your research
and
eric says things and people you know
will say well he doesn't publish it
that's not really true if you look back
in and you know if you're willing to
take the time
and go back you will see and been able
to verify everything that he has said
has come true now whether or not gay you
know geometric unity will come true or
we can prove it in some sense whatever
that means
that's something you and i are working
on but i would not spend my time
investigating it if i didn't think you
had credibility
and because of the nature of physics we
there's a there's a saying and one of my
russian advisors
say every five years you must rewrite
the literature meaning
that you basically forget everything
that came before you and you act
and this is i do this too like i just
rediscovered the wheel
and this is common thing and the problem
is when people cite that it's like
wikipedia will
have a reference eric weinstein is the
deep right you know whatever i don't
even know far
right and then and then someone will
cite that wikipedia article in a
newspaper article and now it's
it's that's the game and the game the
game is to misremember who did what
and you know let's be honest you have a
you had a young woman of color from a
developing country immigrant to the
united states
comes up with what i think of uh in this
collaboration as
the most profound theory at the heart of
neoclassical economics
completely foundational buried by a
bunch of old people who didn't
understand it
never knew gage theory didn't understand
group theory
because it threatened them and what i'm
really upset about and one of the
reasons that i'm
sort of avoidant about doing all this is
that i've watched
what seems like tens of stories if not
hundreds
of very established people making sure
that people who need
the the citations and the attribution
that they never get it and they don't
have careers and so effectively what we
have is we have a group of people
who just doesn't know that they
absolutely have no choice in who they
cite
if they're going to cite work that is
done by people
who are struggling to establish
themselves and
i think that part of the problem is many
of the smartest people in my generation
are working outside of the academy
whereas before
the smartest people were working inside
and in large measure it's because
the people who got established stopped
feeling that they had to acknowledge
with attribution
where they got these great new ideas
from and it's just
i don't know of a nice way of saying it
but we've done this with
with telomeres on my program we're going
to do it with gage theory and economics
we're going to do it
with self dual yang mills equations and
they're
cyborg whitten uh extension we're going
to do with geometric unity and the real
reason that i'm avoiding talking about
this is that i
it's the attribution game that i won't
put up with right and once bitten and
twice bitten and three times better and
i agree
no my point is i'm not i'm just not
we're large enough that we will never
have to put up with this again
so there's a question what does
geometric unity say about singularities
in a black hole well what it what it
gives is hope
we see when you have equations the
equations
may have an essentially defective nature
which
manifests in what we might call
essential singularities
and so when penrose for example um
showed that you couldn't get rid of the
singularities in a black hole or at the
beginning
of a symmetrical early universe with
like a
friedman walker robertson metric
what it was effectively saying was that
einstein
gave us equations that had defects in
them and since his equations seem kind
of perfect in a certain weird way
it was disturbing does do the perfect
equations have it have a defect or does
the defect tell us that the equations
are imperfect and that there's something
more defined
the key problem with einstein is that
einstein's first
act is to say let x be a space-time
manifold
and it's so hard to figure out what you
can say before that
there's so little structure that
einstein einstein is getting so much
power out of simply choosing a
space-time metric on a manifold
that we don't know what we can do to go
beyond
einstein's one of the reasons why
einstein has been so stable is that the
assumptions are so radically
minimalistic then one of the things that
geometric unity tries to do
is that there's this old quote where
einstein says my equations are like a
mansion half of which is made of fine
marble the other half
of cheap wood and so we've sort of made
the assumption that the fine marble
might be the problem and if you wanted
to bury a body
and have nobody dig it up you'd put it
under something that nobody wants to
destroy
and so in some sense the idea of getting
underneath the concept of a space-time
metric
to replace that with a fiber bundle with
two separate spaces and a relationship
involving metrics
that isn't a metric itself it's quite
hard to do that and the hope
of course is is that by getting pre to
einstein by going upstream from einstein
which is almost impossible
that maybe we can have an equation that
doesn't have singularities and i'm
betting
that geometric unity will not actually
have those singularities
okay question from aardvark what
importance would you
put on understanding proofs for learning
the mathematical machinery gauge
theoretics of high-level
physics it's a little hard for me to
parse that do you well let's try it yeah
what importance would you put on
understanding proofs so i'm guessing
that proofs might be the
the yeah for learning the mathematical
machine
all right so are proofs the right way of
emphasizing
the pedagogy around the machinery for
high level physics
i think that's an interesting question
actually because what it's saying is
proof theory tends to be more about
mathematicians and what they need
on the other hand if i'm a physicist is
is it right to take on the
mathematician's need for rigor
or is it good enough to have a physicist
kind of working knowledge of something
that proxies
for that kind of fussy finishing school
attitude that the mathematicians bring
to the table
i don't know i think the mathematicians
have actually proven
that they think about these things
better than the physicist the great
danger
is is that let's imagine that we got it
wrong you shouldn't model
physics by geometry if you only knew
geometry you wouldn't have the ability
to even formulate that thought
now i don't think that physics is
non-geometric
but you always have to remember that so
far the mathematics and the geometry
is still the map of the territory it may
be a very accurate map but the map is
not yet the territory and so
we have to be a little bit careful that
if what we do is really learn
only from books about geometry then we
have to say
if we've missed anything if we've
mis-encoded anything we may be trapped
forever if we don't go back to the lab
okay super chat from the ohio from the
great state of ohio
what do you think about the new trend of
econo physics papers
challenging economics orthodoxy and the
kinetic exchange model
if you have read about it which i assume
you have uh i've not read about the
kinetic exchange model the issue
of econophysics
there are these different intellectual
disciplines that cross
paths inside of markets so finance for
example
has a very different feel intellectually
than does macro then does micro then
does econo physics then does the gauge
theoretic physics that pni have
introduced
and so what i would say is that in
general the core
of neoclassical economics is a field
evenly divided between [ __ ] and
insight
and they don't like the [ __ ] being
disrupted because the [ __ ] gives the
power
to economics where there is [ __ ]
economists can say
well you have to do things this way or
that way and they can wield political
power
like saying we have to free up our trade
or we have to change the way we measure
inflation
so they transfer a lot of wealth
claiming that it's coming
out of pure theory what are we doing
here brian i'm looking at the
uh chat room okay and in that
um i just don't know which camera okay
so in that way the problem is economists
don't like things that weren't invented
inside of economics
in general because they don't know
whether it's going to restrict
the freedom to go to jackson hole
for the meetings of the macro economists
and davos and all of these things
and that they'd have to say well we used
to tell you what you needed to do
but now we we have to surrender to some
model that some kid came up with so
i do think that in part it's a cultural
issue where economics would rather have
power than accuracy and diverse economic
opinions
okay so uh we're gonna take a little
break for a second to do a quick
interlude this is by one of my super
fans out there miguel
proprietor of the yeti tears the eddie
tears channel on instagram
follow him and follow him on youtube as
well he's a great fan of eric as well
[Music]
we brought some props you have brought
some props with you and i think this
might help to answer
uh kushal thacker's question or help to
it and at least
encourage an answer what are some books
to equip oneself with the mathematics
required to comprehend the references
your talks make as someone who doesn't
have a quantitative background the
reason i say that
is that i think you think geometrically
and you think
geometrically in terms of physics so
some of these items that you brought i
want to
and i should say we are working and i
would love help with this
i don't know how we can recruit the into
the impossible podcast and the portal
podcast together
you got to be careful there are a lot of
crazy people out there no there's a lot
of wonderful people out there and
they're a lot of women but they're a lot
of crazy don't think i don't see you
yeah there they are there you are but
listen eric did a wonderful podcast with
his brother brett
and in that you go through a
mathematical description for a
non-mathematician
uh well that was the one on his on his
part his podcast yes
and you go through a very very nice
geometric interpretation i've started a
project
to turn that into a mini e-book just
what you've talked about there not
geometric unity what's a fiber bundle we
were talking about this later
um if people can help with this maybe on
discord or wherever we can figure it out
i think that would make an answer to
kushal thacker's question
you'd have something geometrical we'd
have images we'd have
uh and maybe animated movies for the
ebook or whatever where we show what is
a fiber bundle
what is a uh what does it mean to have
covariance what does it mean
to be a one form even simple and then
build up so you'd have the mathematical
prerequisite
for a possible approach to understanding
geometric unity or
any theory of geometric physics what do
you think about that
um well this is something i do piecemeal
a lot so for example brian is um
forcing me to hold up a water wiggle
which they did not have what's the name
of it i think so you didn't get this
from that riley read podcast
um passing over that in silence the
water wiggle
is in fact a taurus it is a donut
filled with fluid and they've suspended
some little stars and things
in the fluid but the key thing is is
that
the tube rotates through your hands
while you're holding the material the
material isn't moving in your hands due
to friction
but the torus is rolling and it's very
easy to
let go of it and have it just slip on
out that thing
is an example of what we would call a u1
principle bundle
over the one sphere so in other words
the two
the two-dimensional torus which is the
surface of a bagel
is itself a fiber bundle with fiber u1
where u1 is a fancy name for the circle
over a second copy of the circle
and this thing which it's doing by
rolling i mean the kids
can play with it but what it really is
is would be called the
g action of the structure group on the
principal bundle
so this would be called a pg bundle and
this rolling
motion would be called the g action of
u1 on its own total space of a principle
bundle
so while i'm saying u1 principal bundle
everything is super confusing on the
other hand you played with a water
wiggle presumably at some point or your
kids have
and that is actually the same thing so
you have some super confusing language
and then you have some toy that you
actually have intimate physical
familiarity with
visceral yeah i found it very and so
that's
then you take the same structure which
is a different version of the donut in
the form of a hair tie picked up at some
boutique in la
and if you start to rotate
some of these rings in some directions
but different amounts
that's exactly what we mean by a gauge
transformation on the nose
it's not that's an analogy to a gauge
transformation to the extent
that you can see that is the surface of
a torus
that rotation of that hair scrunchie is
actually what we mean by a gauge
transformation now you can also go to
sean carroll's mindscapes
and ask him well what's a gage theory
and he'll show you
some equations and some principles and
he'll say everything right he's very
clear and very clean
but the idea that nobody seems to have
realized that scrunchies and water
wiggles are principal bundles in which
we can talk about cage transformation
i don't know what we're doing i feel
like we're just completely dropping the
ball on pedagogy where all we're doing
is talking about entanglement over and
over again
and the multiverse and it's enough
already
the last time we constructed this in the
keating laboratory unless you think
we're not doing experimental physics
well explain what this is well what this
was
was a model of the observers
so the geometric unity theory is all
about
um a concept called the observers
and if you if if space-time were a
circle rather than a four-dimensional
manifold and we consider a circle
one-dimensional even though many of you
would call it two-dimensional which
would be
mathematically inaccurate if
we lived on a circle then the observers
would be a gadget that looked like this
it would be the space of
all possible rulers that we could put
at any point on a circle and it would
break up
into two two directions one which would
be the
the ruler direction and the other which
would be the circular direction
so rulers plus circles gives you a tube
and then the idea would be that you have
this uh
bundle which i've called the chimeric
bundle and never mind you won't
many of you won't know what a bundle is
but it breaks up into two pieces one
piece lies along
this space of all metrics space of all
rulers space of all measurement devices
whatever you want to call it
and part of it sticks out and the whole
game is to get the part that sticks out
to go along
the ruler to be a complementary
direction not perpendicular but along
the ruler
so my point here is brian brian's a
physicist
we were able to use this to just talk
about
what the observers is what geometric
unity does
using a simple example we can build to
get our intuition into higher dimensions
because many of you don't have the
background to say what a bass space a
fiber bundle is
a horizontal bundle pull back there's a
whole bunch of gadgetry
but the key point is what we're really
doing is building
things that can be seen and then
generalizing them into the realm where
we can't see anything
and that's part of what we can do is we
can create
concrete objects which people can say
okay i didn't understand what he said
but i saw a tube there was a toothpick
going along the tube there was a
toothpick going away from the tube there
were some lines on it
what the f is going on and then as long
as you're willing to see it out
i guarantee you there's nowhere for it
to hide you can't escape
then you've got the thing trapped
because you actually have a physical
model of it
and then you just have to bring that up
to higher dimensions
back to the smithsonian uh hold on a
second so talk very briefly
about this really cool exercise that you
did with a young
person uh going through the double helix
so the analog between
reading about you know the play-by-play
of the lakers versus
the spasky fisher match uh and playing
through the chess pieces
on your own the difference in visceral
retention and comprehension
well actually the people who figured
this out weirdly were the gracies in
brazil
and the uh the gracie challenge was such
that they said come anyone who thinks
you have a better fighting system than
we have and we'll we'll fight you
and the gracie started remembering all
of the fights
and playing them back as they occurred
they'd film them
they'd learn what all the moves are and
they would pl replay
wrestling matches grappling matches and
striking
matches as if they were
um chess games and so what i did with my
kids
was to read the double helix which is an
incredibly well-written
book i mean it stands as a work of
literature to say nothing of the science
but then the part where they actually
work out the pairing relationships
between the
nucleotides in the nucleic acid
um all takes place because a guy named
jerry donahue informs the mu
says you know all the books are wrong
it's like what well all the books are
wrong they all have hydrogen atoms in
the wrong places on the nucleotides
and within two pages or something jim
watson has figured out the right
hydrogen bonds
from a to c and t to g and that
action you can actually play through
with your children
by moving the hydrogen atoms on a cons
on a
but a bunch of plastic chemical building
blocks
and then you watch you recapitulate the
history of 1953
yeah and you're actually it is visceral
right and i'd highly recommend
buying the book with a series of um
with a model for molecular for for
making molecules yeah just like i got
this on amazon thanks to your
recommendation actually i got this 20
years ago is that right this is a klein
bottle
so this is imagine trying to read about
this explain this etc
talk about uh complex uh concepts to
to try to get your head around but then
to actually have one of these a klein
bottle i think the guy's up in berkeley
cliff stole cliff stahl yes so i bought
these uh from amazon he has a store on
amazon where he sells these things
not too expensive what a bargain 50
bucks you get a climbing ball
so steven's asking the etymology of gage
i think that comes from railroad gauges
uh basically the fact that hermann vile
i think was the one who
used the word gauge engaged theory uh
which was the original
attempt um to show that something was
scale invariant the original gauge
theory wasn't
that successful but it came back as a
concept years later
good okay let's go through we have some
more questions coming in here
so thank you stephen for that question
uh
let's see we've got a whole bunch of
questions about 700 people there oh a
big ticket one from andrew carey
what does space time emerge from so this
priest
let's unpack this a little bit what does
it mean to emerge
what is space time does it uh
how does it and what could it possibly
emerge from well that's
that's a great question because that's
part of what we were talking about with
einstein locking us out
when you say let x be a sp be a four
dimensional space time
um you're you're foreclosing it it's
emerging from anywhere because you're
putting it in by hand
so about the most minimal thing you can
say that is
prior to that would be let x be a
manifold
but without a metric because it's the
space-time metric that turns an ordinary
four-dimensional manifold
and i've been saying this recently just
bought an amplifier
and it has treble
medium bass and reverb on it
and those four dimensions define a four
dimensional manifold just by buying an
amp
i immediately got a four manifold but it
didn't have a metric on it if i say well
base is perpendicular to mid-level and
mid is perpendicular to treble and that
they're all perpendicular to reverb
then i would have angle and then if i
have a 0 to 10 scale on all of them i
would have a metric and that would put
rulers and angles but that would
probably give it not a space time but a
galilean
sort of a metric because reverb would be
measured in the same 0 to 10 scale then
if i made it 0 to negative 10
it would get closer to the concept where
reverb was somehow different
okay well how do we get a space-time
metric to emerge the concept of the
observers is to say
work over the space of all possible
ruler protractor combinations
you pick up what might a computer
scientist might call technical debt
so you now have a much bigger space now
not only do you have the four original
dimensions but you've got four rulers to
measure
size in all of those dimensions so
that's four plus four equals eight and
then you have six protractors
that give you the angles between uh
t with x t with y t with z x with y x
with z
y with z right and so those extra six
protractors
together with the four rulers together
with the original four direct directions
gives you 14 dimensions
and a space-time metric is then a map
from your original four-dimensional
space shoving it
into a larger 14-dimensional world but a
14-dimensional world that was built from
the original four-dimensional structure
to receive it
and so then you see einstein is
basically giving us a tiny
filament inside of a much larger space
as a space-time metric
what you then have to do is to accept
that that's telling you to do physics on
the 14 dimensional object and interpret
it
on the filament but it's actually
happening much more generally
inside of a large space for four
dimensional space time would emerge from
this 14-dimensional
observer yes so um one other
point to note uh andrew is that there
are uh proposals the
uh hawking harker hawking heartle
no boundary proposal is a suggestive of
space being permanent but time emerging
somehow cleaving off and being
nucleated at a at a certain moment
that we call the big bang or we would
call without a singularity
having to require the infinite amount of
temperature and density that seemed to
be required at least in the original
formulation of the hot but i would also
say that in my model
there's parts of this observers that
look like for
space in no time two time and two space
three time in one space four times zero
space
all of those things have a reality to
them but we aren't we aren't in a sector
where we can see that reality
good so we've got uh probably about uh
15 20 more minutes to go here got lots
of people in the chat room reminder
talking to eric weinstein
on the into the impossible podcast find
him at the portal podcast
and find him on youtube is your channel
just like eric weinstein
probably eric eric weinstein put that in
the comments people if you know the
actual name of his channel
okay what would you say ryan is asking
uh eric what would you say
studying non-linear dynamics and complex
systems now will be worthwhile
and or would you say in the next 10
years it often feels
though a lot of it is hype thank you
ryan you know nobody knows these things
like there are lots of ideas that mostly
live as
some kind of hype until suddenly
somebody figures something out to do
with it i think a good example of this
is um brownie in motion
in finance where we didn't really know
what to do with that model up until
the 60s when black shoals merton came
along
and showed us how to price options using
stochastic differential calculus
so if you'd asked me about stochastic
differential calculus before that i
would say maybe it's nice but it doesn't
really do anything
and that's all you need is one paper to
kick your ass and say okay apparently i
had no idea what i was talking about
um so you know the horrible advice is go
into a field that is
incorrectly priced go into a field in
which it doesn't seem that anything is
going on
and then show that everybody had it
wrong which would be like
if you understood the block chain in
2010
uh you know you just had to wait for a
while where everybody thought you were
an idiot and now you're gonna you can
invite them all in your private plane to
your private island
so i had on shelly glashow yeah this
week and one thing i we didn't get the
debrief after that it was a lovely
podcast i'll find it earlier in this
week
um and shelley said there was a point
when gelman you know kind of put
forth the eightfold way when he was
literally when shelley
was literally one of the few people on
earth who understood it and so he
immediately knew that he wasn't going to
be the one that discovered it and
you know won the nobel prize for that he
would win his nobel prize you know
17 years later for uh lecture week
unification
but shelley knew that that galman was
right
and so but nobody else believed it for
years people didn't believe that galmon
was right
and so he started doing all these
calculations making use of this insider
trading is the way i took away from it
and uh do you ever you know do you think
that that can be applied in
in other systems in physical you know
and physically
i can say it openly like um
pia milani's thesis revolutionized all
of economic theory and it hasn't been
understood
if you want to do something
revolutionary i promise you
that that's been a it's an exam it's an
arbitrage i can share it with the world
nobody will do anything with it because
um
the the world decided to stand in the
way of that progress that's an
incontrovertible
fact to me and years from now it'll come
out and it will somebody will say why
did we not understand that this was done
50 years earlier
and then there'll be this series of
podcast appearances where it's like well
didn't he keep telling us that
yeah because we've all got our heads
wedged up there so far we can't see
straight
that's the general nature of academics
it's not really a claim
about oh my god you know you're bragging
so much about the various things that
have happened in your family no
it's very different than that it's a
claim that american
stem research has been going great guns
and that the baby boomers and silent
generation
more or less held back a ton of
different
insights this is why we're still dealing
with string theory all the time is the
string theory is a movement almost
entirely
moved by baby boomers in earlier and
it's not a movement of gen x it's not a
millennial movement
yeah and so you know this this comment
at plank about funeral by funeral
i'm sorry to say it it has much more to
it than it should
should we take a few questions that are
really technical in nature rather than
super chat questions
okay your dog someone's calling me a dog
all right
technical question eigen bros were
asking about the relationship of yang
mills theory within
gu let's find the question so we can
answer great
in geometric unity there are effectively
four
major equations that exist before you
get to gu
from the standard model and general
relativity that do
deal with each of the the different spin
fields
so for spin 0 and spin 1
that is the higgs field and the vector
potentials
those things belong to an equation
that is generated analogously to yang
mills theory
if you think about the curvature tensor
as being an obstruction
to a certain differential complex being
a co homology theory
if d squared does not equal zero but d
squared equals curvature
coupled to a connection then the idea is
that you can take the size of the
curvature square that and use that as
what we would call a lagrangian
an objective function that penalized
some states of the world and privilege
others and that's how we do physics
well what you do is you form a bosonic
complex that's two-step uh you have two
differential operators you would imagine
that if you compose them you would get a
second-order differential operator you
don't then you think maybe i get a first
order you don't all of those terms die
you're left with a zeroth order term you
take the no the size of that and square
it just as you do
in yang mills theory now the the problem
is is that the two other main equations
by the way the eigenbros have been
pretty loyal followers of this stuff so
it's a pleasure to be able to answer
this
the other two equations are the einstein
field equation for the spin two field
and the dirac equation for the spin one
half fields
and those in fact go into a different
set of equations that come from the
square root of the original lagrangian
so just the way einstein took the square
root
sorry just the way dirac took the square
root
of the uh klein gordon lagrangian
and got the dirac lagrangian and the
dirac equations
we take a a square root of this
second order um lagrangian which
produces the obstruction analogous to
yang mills theory and get a second
lagrangian which is much closer to a
churn simon structure and a derock
structure
so the einstein and the dirac go into
one place in the theory
and they unify in that square rooted
part
and the higgs field and the
yang mills field go into a different
portion that have to do
with minimizing a norm square
of an obstruction term to a two-step
elliptic complex much the way
you would in the deformation theory of
self-dual yang mills
okay now this might be a a technical
question or it could be
full of something else david kearsey
eric did you study the relationship
between seifert fiber spaces a
geometries of three-space
and the non-abelian finite simple groups
27 sporadic groups
uh pre-order lisi's favorite 18 simple
groups
fam your favorite g2 do you understand
this
uh vaguely um
not i not as you've not as you've
written it
i mean i am very interested in
exceptional algebra i've been much more
interested in the large exceptional lead
groups than in the finite groups
i don't think there is anything profound
the way garrett would think
about e8 and its relationship to the
world i think it's an artifact of
putting together spinners
and adjoint representations of
orthogonal groups it's tantalizing but
it doesn't really get
you a hyper unification without super
symmetry because
in fact you have to quantize the whole
thing bosonically i don't buy that
garrett's
move to infinite dimension solve the
problem i hope to be proven wrong
um but i'll be on the show in a couple
weeks that's great
but again um you know my feeling about
this
is large exceptional lead groups are
something i'd love to talk about i
haven't found them to be particularly
important within physics and i
that was my second favorite unification
scheme i'm glad garrett is doing it so i
can think about something else because
my
favorite is much more uh important to me
than is that second one
all right do you want to try another
technical one uh
why look for one why is stephen wolfram
wrong in your opinion can there only be
one as the highlander said
well sort of um my hope
is that he's not wrong but i hope that
if my theory
turns out to be right his won't be as
important and that's not
personal to stephen i'm perfect be if
i'm wrong he's one of the people i'd
love to be right
but what i believe is is that once you
have a theory that bootstraps itself
from four degrees of freedom you don't
need a lot to get started you don't need
a supercritical
cellular automata to give you everything
you just need it to give you four
degrees of freedom and if you're willing
to accept
you know sweet salty sour and bitter
then pretty much that's as good as uh
treble mid
bass and reverb you don't really need
something to get you started so if i'm
right
it doesn't mean steven would have to be
wrong but if i were right stephen would
have to be
not as important as uh
as the role that he's planning to play
and if i'm wrong then we're going to
need to get the complexity in some way
and he's going to have to somehow
[Music]
do that in his theory
so uh my friend eden rafaeli asked the
question is academia becoming too
terrified
took that off the screen it's not a
technical question this ted talk
whiz-bang we talk we joke about
wormholes oh time warps and you see
things michio kaku goes on lex friedman
and talks about
the god comes in here and you know and
it's just like give me a break
if you will two two twins separated
because
lex is a smart guy why does he fall for
this nonsense it's not that it's the
the problem is that we're we have to
keep people excited
we've we have to keep them as state so
do we have to testify like
that's what i'm trying i'm not trying to
do it i know you're not
but what i'm trying to do is to try to
say look you want to talk serious stuff
we can talk about hop
vibrations we can talk about principal
bundles we can talk about spinners we
can talk about any of the
experiments yeah beautiful experiments
beautiful experiments as we've been
talking
about for some reason
we're in whiz-bang mode and we we
want we think that the universe is all
about us and that studying physics
is going to bring us closer to some
different way to stare into our own
navels and i hope that that's true
but that's not the only reason we do
this stuff we do it to get it right
and i'm sorry to say but
part of physics that we get part of
science that we get wrong is we tell
everybody that
science is exciting science is
interesting right no it's not
sometimes it's dull sometimes nothing
happens for a decade
and if if you're constantly expecting to
be on the edge of your seat about what's
happening in physics when for my
thinking right right theoretical physics
has not budged much
in certain ways in 50 years just under
okay if you don't have that kind of
patience you probably don't belong in
the field and if you're impatient then
you better get in here
and uh you know bring a shovel and a mop
if you dropped a trillion dollars on
either theoretical or experimental
physics which would have a bigger impact
um my feeling is is that you get the
biggest impact from immunizing
physicists from having
to be scrutinized meaning what
immunizing them
they shouldn't be i don't like
transparency you don't
no okay f transparency we have so much
transparency like every
you're laughing because you know that
everyone thinks transparency is a good
thing
what we need is more transparency why
can't we have transparency we need
transparency
you know we need we need feedback best
practices we need
some way of scoring things better
metrics you're de-vitalizing
everything about the field right
somebody should tell you take your h
index and and take your your your forms
in triplicate
and go fill them out somewhere else
because we're trying to do science in
this place
go get us some money and then bl you
know black the windows out so nobody can
see what we're doing
and let's make progress but if you do
all this transparency stuff what you get
is group think
and how's that working out for us since
1984 in the anomaly cancellation and
strength
it's been a disaster so less
transparency
we need more smart people we need to get
the people who aren't very smart not
very generative not very creative out of
the field
and we have to realize that this is
super serious business that's
contributed so much to the economy that
it should never have to beg for another
penny
yeah but i mean that sounds great and
you know we shouldn't nobody should go
hungry but there are priorities right so
how do we balance these priorities
i mean you made a suggestion when you
first appeared on my podcast oh we got a
tax
you know semiconductor instructions
because the physicists invented the
but no theorists looked and said look at
these uh equations of brillouin zones
and
and transistors let me pre in in
semiconductors let me predict that this
will have an application in super
computing
it's different than this you want to
screw yourself over as a society let me
give you an idea of how to do it
efficiently so you can screw up
the the power of the united states and
our economy for the foreseeable future
by all means ask physicists to justify
what they do every four seconds make
sure that they
tell you about the importance of
understanding the early universe
in terms of whether or not it can make
your microwave oven five seconds faster
okay and make sure that you get as much
say
about choosing who goes into the field
as possible not on ability but on
extraneous
details right and then make sure that
you're getting
update reports every few seconds to know
that people are actually making progress
and everyone will lie to you in the
field the field will grind to a halt
if you want to make actual progress and
increase the diversity of the field give
the field money
and stop asking so many questions let
them do what they know how to do best
and stop pushing them to lie about all
the success that they're having
because they're failing it should be
succeeded or failing based on
not what technical applications it
produces right the problem is that it
has technical applications yes but we
come to experts my point is that physics
has proven itself
so many times that if you're going to
ask what have you done for me lately
it's clear you don't understand the
history of theoretical physics and its
impact on the economy and on geopolitics
and so go read up and then come back and
you'll understand why it's really
important to leave physicists alone
okay let's see we've got questions about
ufos i don't know if you want to answer
those
should we build a bigger collider i'll
take that one no i don't think we should
build a super a bigger collider
and i gave the example when i talked to
barry barris that will air next week i
think it'll air next week
and i said it was good for him
personally that the super conducting
super collateral was canceled
because we ended up building or the
world ended up building
a super collider of sorts called the lhc
which did what the ssc was designed to
do the only natural target at that time
was the higgs that was the last missing
element in the 1990s when it was
cancelled by
uh during the early 1990s 1993 i think
and and it caused barry to search for a
new job
and the job that he settled on was
called ligo and ligo made a detection
many many many many years later
and in fact years after you know three
or four years after actually two years
after three years after the announcement
of the higgs detection at the lhc
for which peter higgs and and glert won
the
nobel prize but none of the 6 000
experimental brothers and sisters my
brothers
won a nobel prize so he missed out he
would have missed out
on this little golden medallion which i
stole from him
when he wasn't looking um had not been
cancelled so
tell me what this future collider would
be used for and i'll tell you
uh if it's a good enough use of taxpayer
money oh man yes go for it okay
no we should definitely build the next
collider and it may
find absolutely nothing and it's not
necessarily true that
by just increasing energy we always find
something if somebody told you that they
lied to you
the reason we should build this thing is
completely different than what brian
said
in my opinion in my opinion the reason
to build this thing is
that we have the money we have the
know-how we're going to lose the
know-how
and we're losing contact with the
successful part of humanity
we we don't know why should i build this
why if i don't find anything
there's no reason to think no it's not
the right reason
we should build it even if it fails it's
cheap we've earned it
stop being stop being so stingy and
ridiculous about this
this is the we've also created a
disaster
in unleashing the power of nuclear
weapons and if
theoretical physics doesn't go further
my concern is is that we've marched us
into the valley of death and we're not
going to find a way out and
in part this is already dangerous enough
the next
thing to do is to understand particle
theory and physical theory
to see if there's any way to actually
get somewhere outside of our solar
system and
quite honestly this is i feel
embarrassed
even saying this when i'm talking about
people like jeff bezos
and bill gates elon musk you know with
tens of billions of dollars
it's just like for f's sake you know i'm
happy to not sit on top of the fact that
a lot of that was
taxpayer-funded stuff that then got
monopolized and concentrated in a few
places
but for f's sake you know
if you're gonna have ridiculous levels
of concentration
don't give me three million dollars for
a little cute prize
keep your money cut it out you know if
you've got real money to throw around
we should be actually building things
that make a difference and matter
and this is ridiculous and i just i also
feel embarrassed on behalf of the
physicists talking about money
and can we afford to do this of course
we can afford to do this look i never
say that we should take all these
theorists and
again you and i were debating this last
night over some beverages very good ones
very good ones yes for japanese
beverages um we were debating
you know theory in in some sense is
is abundant and plentiful and
experiments are very expensive just the
fact that there's only one experiment
that you can name in particle physics
which would supersede the current one
whereas there could be 10 or 12
different theories and different
dimensions so we disagree about that too
i say that the number of real
theories is almost zero because the
constraints are so high didn't used to
be the case
but i think that really what's going on
and this is important thing is the kind
of thing i can say that you can't
is is that brian is quite correct that
our experimental friends are not getting
a huge amount of mind share and we were
talking about like the great experiments
the cobalt 60 experiment with respect to
the weak force
or the iron off bone effects which
showed us some aspect of
electromagnetism
super late in the game in the 1950s that
could have been done at any time that's
so mind-blowing we can't even think
about it
or with the famous you know magnetic
monopole that one time went through uh
palo alto as laboratory right
so we've got scandals we've got the
discovery of the higgs particles we've
got the
neutrinos coming from 1987 a supernova
jason wilson discovering the microwave
background
serendipitously yes what's what's the
old uh what's the name of the antenna
homedale holmdale
antenna new jersey so there's so many
great stories
we've been remiss telling the
experimental side of our story
and i think it's really important to
give the experimentalists they're doing
not only fetishized theory yeah why is
it that we have
yeah when you ask a theorist it's it's
you it's lisa randall it's jan 11. these
are all friends of mine i've been on the
podcast
it's brian green it's michio kaku when
is it going to be
you know elena april who leads the xenon
one tone experiment well but it's also
i mean to be fair even in the theorists
case why isn't it
uh edward whitten why isn't it
uh carlo ravelli like we have a bunch of
these people
who actually try to theorize about this
stuff
and the podcast world thinks that brian
greene
sean carroll jaina myself you are
are where it's at it's up to us look i
mean
i can be resentful of those characters
at times
but it's really important to say that
the mainstream of theoretical physics is
concentrated not in the podcast world
but at the institute for advanced study
okay so we're running short eric and i
are going to be departing to welcome in
a very important ritual in both of our
lives the
jewish sabbath is coming soon uh let me
see if we can figure out
a couple of more good questions here if
you had a 3d computer model of your
paper tube what things would you want to
do with it
i don't think it's just about the paper
tube you want you want a model of
uh of the observers in uh well
just to say the model of the observers
the circle would be replaced by let's
say a four-dimensional
torus and the one dimension
of along the tube would be replaced by
ten extra dimensions
those ten dimensions would be both
related to something called so10
theory as well as the 10 coupled
non-linear equations that
constitute general relativity so it
makes a linkage between those tens and
actually really something called the
petit salaam
model but that has to do with ex low
dimensional exceptional isomorphisms
tyler what's your question i can't find
it so i'll i'll give you a free question
if you asked a
100 super clean you ask it again really
quickly just in the chat you don't have
to do another
super chat tyler's a friend of mine i
want to make sure we get that in
um what kind where does consciousness
come into geometric unity
uh it's a great question um i think it's
really important that we stop
interposing ourselves between
the world outside and what we are
and i i just i've become very
disheartened that we have to be at the
center of
everything i don't think the universe is
about us
um maybe it's about us maybe there's a
creator and
there's a whole point to this thing but
we've got to stop act
asking what is the universe done for me
it's it's sort of embarrassing that we
we've taken this thing of
infinite complexity and we've decided
that it's about humans and it just
isn't and i really want us to stop
making this about consciousness
about love about spirituality the
universe is about the universe what we
should be figuring out is what are we
doing to relate to it rather than trying
to
shoehorn it into a whole shaped like
us right so a question about academia
why it's getting so hard i like to make
the analogy imagine if it was possible
to get into oh someone's asking about
patenting something
actually i want to talk about things
that mention things that sound technical
yeah i know i'm looking for it can you
patent anything and no so the re that's
not necessarily
the various gauge groups yeah go for it
right you read it out
where do the various gauge groups eg su
2 su 3
lay in geometric community flavor space
color space do these arise from g use 14
dimensional construction
in 14 dimensions you have a four
dimensional space and a 14 dimensional
space the four-dimensional space
is embedded in the 14 or even immersed
in the 14-dimensional
the 14-dimensional space carries a
bundle that is isomorphic to the tangent
bundle
but is not canonically isomorphic it has
a metric
if you do spinners on that
14-dimensional bundle
i believe you get to the unitary group
in 128 dimensions
through the spin representation so spin
14 c
i think goes to u14c or something like
that
you're pulling back that bundle that you
you
sorry you 128 uh
via map from spin 14c into into that
large unitary group and that group is
going to contain the su-3 the su-2
the u1 and i think it's going to do it
along the petit
salaam breakdown of ten dimensional
space
into six dimensional space in
four-dimensional space su-4
which is typically the pt salon group is
exceptionally isomorphic to spin 6 and
su-2 cross su-2 is exceptionally
isomorphic to spin
four and so the six and the four add up
to 10 and i believe that that's how that
that story goes someone asked about the
shape of particles within geometric
unity
does not even make sense but i like i
like the technical question that we just
got that was a good example good use of
our time something that's about
patenting something i know i don't care
i know that but listen to me just as it
has a practical application
understanding you know the strong force
the weak force but you know what i'm
trying to i'm tired of this
this is about what it's about it's about
trying to understand the universe
and talking about how do you get rich
from it what can we do with it
i know yeah i know that that's what he
meant but what i mean is
could this unlock you know technology
could it unlock potential devastating
power i am much more afraid that it's
right than it's wrong if it's wrong it
was a beautiful dream and it's over
if it's right then we have to worry
about the consequences what can you do
with this that you couldn't do before
all right last question i want to take
sorry tyler
if you're hearing this ask your question
one more time i'll try to get it to eric
uh last question let's try to find one
more technical question
infinity biggest version of infinity i
don't know what that means
parent painting can you create someone
asked about music
yeah but i don't do any of that i want
to do
serious questions about the theory when
you talk about information
because you know one of the things is
that i'll be if i talk fluff
people will say well that's all that
fluff stuff you do on the internet
and then if i say no you want to talk to
technical then what people will say is
well you lost everybody so there's
sort of no win is bell's theorem does it
appear does
uh collapse of the waveform where does
the standard uh
aspects of quantum um of the you know
unitarity to collapse et cetera does it
live does it have a place
within gu for our final question for
well i would say this
different metrics sample different
portions of metric space
from the four-dimensional piece so if
you had a different metric
then you're having a different
observation of a different filament
within the 14-dimensional space
so i believe that that will have
something to do with the quantization
but it's phrased
as a natural geometric theory because
natural geometric theories post the 70s
have the opportunity
for geometric quantization since we
figured out what to do with hamiltonian
mechanics in the symplectic geometry
category
by forming pre-quantum line bundles and
then taking sections of the pre-quantum
line bundles
to give the state space of the theory
generating the quantum out of the
classical
so while it's not exactly true there's
an old saying that quantization
is an art not a functor but it's less
true after the 70s it's more of a
functor
the quantizations often suggest
themselves that the theory is
sufficiently geometrically natural
and what this is is a natural geometric
theory that suggests
that its quantization will be the
standard model
and the claim is if you have anything
that's remotely right like three
if you have a natural geometric model
that has three generations of sixteen
particles each with a 3 1 metric and all
if the stuff starts lining up then it's
highly unlikely that the quantization
will be its problem we know how to
quantize a good theory
the problem is is we haven't had a great
theory to quantize
does this question make any sense what
are the fundamental particles made out
of quote frank is asking frank wilcheck
i assume
in string theory particles are explained
in terms of nine dimensional strings
vibrating in this abstract space in time
uh what does gu say about fundamental
particles composition
well that this begins it's
non-revolutionary in this aspect if we
think
that in the standard framework we have
bundles and that these bundles have
sections which are
a fancy name for functions think of the
xy plane as an
example of a bundle the x-axis is its
base space the
translates of the y-axis or its fibers
then functions are called sections
in this new language in that new
language particles
are going to continue to be sections of
bundles so i don't that's not
an area where gu differs from the
standard model in general relativity
all right well i am now so you all were
here you watch this ad free
anyone who comes afterwards is going to
have to suffer through ads
eric i want to thank you so much i want
to take us out with a little music
from our friend mr mcgill at yeti tears
and eric i want to wish you
continued success and continued visits
to uc san diego
many times in the future may we go from
strength to strength together
thank you so much my friend and now
we're off to dinner
thank you for going into the impossible
please subscribe we've got great
interviews coming up with guests such as
kameron vapha
and we have ray weiss barry barish and
many other people coming up
into the impossible podcast may they
find their way from the ucsd podcast to
the portal
great guests
bye everybody thanks so much